A tentacle dress and cheeseburgers flip flops.
It's episode 15
of LÜT.
Keep your doors open with NeatoShop's
gross gutsy zombie
doorstop.
Or be a superhero with these hoodies.
Look how serious he is.
Keep your dog warm with this scarf.
I mean, let's talk about the Millennium
Falcon. Or a Star Wars flight jacket from
adidas.
Studio Swine makes these glasses.
They're just
artwork for now, but are made out of
human hair. A strange, but renewable
resource.
These sticking peel stickers let you give
your electrical sockets fun
faces and Arlyn emailed me this Rubik's Cube
for the blind. You can also pick up a
stack of Rubik's Cube colored sticky
notes or
these notes that are reminders and Tetris.
ShanaLogic provides awesome things.
Currently
they're sold out of these earrings,
but have plenty of kitty tied to a balloon
necklaces. But if you wanna know the
animal on your necklace,
Uncommon Goods will send you a mould to
stick on your pet and send back.
Then they'll make you a custom necklace
in the shape
of your dog's nose.
Japan Trend Shop carries these samurai
underpants authentically designed after
the style of famous historical
warriors. And Peter Bristol makes this
informative dresser
that removes all confusion, while Miriam
Liebana has designed sperm shaped
cutlery
that brings meals to life.
Speaking of manly,
floss your power with this tactical
grilling apron and a handmade ring
scale replica
of a .44 caliber chamber.
For 10 bucks you could split your music with his
branch between your friend and your other friend.
And for 80 bucks you can deconstruct the
lamp into its constituent
pieces. The cord itself wraps around
to produce
the lamp shade. Keep acting smart with a
working feather pen and quill set,
then go against the flow and watch a 3D movie
in 2D.
These glasses from ThinkGeek
isolate one layer of a 3D movie and give you a nice
flat picture. Your free thing this week
comes from "guardianjuan" who recommends
HardlyWork.in,
a site that can adapt your
Facebook into what looks like a
spreadsheet.
Now you can waste time at work
and look like the hardest-working
employee. Perfect.
Back in Kansas I found some great
confusing fireworks. The poopy puppy
actually makes a flaming
bowel movement and this depressed
middle-aged man? Well, he's part of the
500 grams of
black powder baby boomer explosive.
Almost as cool
is Blonde Joke, an explosive covered in
blonde women. Yeah, I don't know either.
But what I do know
is that you should subscribe to
Vsauce for more LÜT.
And as always,
thanks for watching.